hello again I'm now going to be pulling
out my First's from this bucket and
telling you about my first time doing
various things first time when you see
yourself as Elton John I guess it's kind
of the gradual process where you sort of
develop it over time shaving up of my
hairline was a bit brutal sort of made
me look like a kind of egg a sort of
furry egg there's no denying it did make
me look quite a lot like Elton John it's
always exciting when you're an actor and
you're able to kind of transform the
maybe Soviet different first impression
after meeting which a man for the first
time I thought it didn't like me
actually I met him you came on sex and
he was in his trailer and me and Jamie
Powell I would say hello to him yeah I
think I was just a bit I don't know
insecure because now we're really really
really good friends but in the world of
him he's a great actor and I think he's
great personal first role you auditioned
for that you really wanted but went to
someone else people loved asking this
question people love scandal don't know
Billy Lynn in billions long halftime
walk look was jokes but only I've never
seen because I was a little bit
heartbroken but Joe Owen got the role
and he's a very very very good actor so
you don't mind so much when it goes to
someone who's very good but that's the
one that sticks out in my mind first
thing you did to prepare for your
rollers on Johnny rocket when I read out
his Diaries that was very very very
helpful they're fascinating quite
economic in terms of the way they're
written it's sort of very typically you
know a day in the life of you know in
the early 70s really did my laundry
wrote a song called honky cat and that
would be like another day where he says
it wasn't any great mood last night went
to restaurant did a moody smashed a
plate of french fries on its own first
big audition first audition ever went to
was for a play called the last of the
Haussmann's at the National Theatre
which is a role I ended up getting which
was over the moon about the big audition
in terms of on the kind of global scale
it was probably Kingsman the Secret
Service which ovation for when I was
2003 it was very very scary there's the
first time I met Matthew Vaughn but I
actually quite enjoyed it in a way as
well I sort of enjoyed the thrill of
auditions and that kind of the stakes of
it the excitement of it I got that one
as well first celebrity crush
maybe maybe Rachel Weisz vice vice
vice multi award-winning actress Smita
James Bond lovers can remember first
kiss that was horrific I was really
messy just drunk and not fun and it's
just bad technical awful first job just
working my auntie's cafe a lot number
strewth and if you go in there now you
can she has all posters of my films up
in there which is very cute and I just
enjoy working in there because I used to
enjoy sort of the pad back and forth
with the customers and seeing regulars
and having fun the likes to sing in
there a lot as I was working but I was
terrible
and I used to burn a lot of things my
auntie's to fall out quite a lot when I
will actually not knocked not built for
cafe life first acting gig did this play
called the last their husbands I was the
first time I was paid but I had to wear
a dress it was the first time on a stage
of just his woman I loved it absolutely
we loved it at first incorrect for MOU
elevators so I don't know Ashley I think
there have been many my name is
pronounced Taron Egerton
it's not Edgerton that is often
something that people get wrong one of
those things you can't control
everything but for those of you are
watching it's Edgerton please
[Music]